all right guys
bang bang i've got ben here with me
super excited to
talk with them thanks so much for doing
this man thank you for having me it's a
pleasure
absolutely coming to us live from
shanghai
for those that don't know you let's just
start with uh with your background kind
of what did you do
uh before you got into crypto um
so i was in the retail forex business
i sort of i was the starting member of
a current retail fx broker called xm.com
right now it's probably one of the top
five for sure uh retail
forex platform uh
have business all over the globe um so i
was in there for eight years uh
in the end when i left i was managing
the sort of the greater china region uh
with close to 100 staff
all aspect of the forex uh business
uh so i guess it sort of gave me a uh
edge um
you know i was running a platform and
now i'm running by bit
um so it i i believe i could use a lot
of my previous knowledge
is especially on how to handle retail
clients
deliver a product that really built for
the retail
and collect feedbacks from the users and
how to you know
give them the best support and overall
trading experience
so i i guess i'm particularly lucky in
that aspect
yeah yeah what was some of your biggest
takeaways from having run that
kind of global forex product right so i
think that's pretty unique experience
any takeaways you had from that
um take away i i guess is uh um
one thing which is one of the reasons i
started by a bit
is that um at least in forest the the
whole business is very mature
it is very mature and so the overall
trading experience is actually very
very good uh if the platform is doing
the right thing
uh there's all the different tools you
can provide to a client
whether it's customer support whether
it's the trading product whether it's a
uh indicator or a education sort of
platform and all of that
um it was very established so there was
nothing
too much to worry about in terms of the
product but looking into crypto uh when
i first got into it by
uh end of uh 2017 um
it was it was just the overall
experience i felt like it was a
a kind of very behind um in the total
overall
kind of experience especially during
volatility uh and that's one of the
reasons i decided to build by bit is i
figured with the
knowledge and the standard uh that i can
take
from forex i can build a product that's
kind of matching the
you know you know the trading standard i
believe the trader can deserve
so i i believe for me the biggest
takeaway is i know
what exchange uh could be and where the
standard should be and
and that's what i want to push the
limits and sort of build the private
platform to
to the standard that i'm used to and
even even beyond yeah
and when you say that the crypto space
was behind in terms of infrastructure
and technology like
what were they lacking or where did you
see the opportunity in terms of things
that existed in the global forex market
that didn't exist in crypto
um it was uh it was the overall trading
experience
so when when when i looked into it
there was only bit max and ok ex at the
time
so i was also checking out majorly on
bitmaps and
first of all the ui ue it was it was
hard for me
coming from retail i know that this
platform
the whole user experience could be
improved uh more users sort of friendly
in
the whole layout and all that and uh
and i was doing a little bit trading
especially during volatility there was
a lot of these type of issues was uh
either overload or
servers not available or it was just
hard
you know during the time and i figured
the industry is
too small what if really we're talking
about mass adoption and
if the mass adoption happens no exchange
can handle that type of volume
and so i figured the opportunities for
sure there
even just from the underground sort of
infrastructure perspective
and but also from customer support
it was no no no live support and also
just here and there the detail the small
parts i feel
uncomfortable and i figured there was a
lot of room to improve
and even now i start to see the whole
industry is getting more mature
for example we start to see a lot more
algo platform
or a more sort of copy trading platform
which is
vastly available in effects in
traditional
i guess industry but now it is getting
more popular uh
people start to see them as a new thing
but it's actually really not um
copy trading this type of stuff has been
happening a lot in
in fx for a long time but you start to
see in crypto
so i i guess as the industry grow and
as we get more mature different sectors
will get more professional and different
products will come out
uh in the form of uh in traditional
space
yeah yeah and so i guess um why start a
company versus just go join one of the
existing ones and help them improve
what was the impetus to actually want to
start a brand new company
uh well hello can you hear me
yep oh sorry i thought it got cut out
yeah
um yeah this is a very good question uh
to be honest number one is i didn't know
anyone i was completely fresh off the
boat in the industry
uh and really realistically speaking if
i didn't know let's see
any of the major guys in the crypto now
i i don't know
you know that the whole bible story
might change so
i didn't know anyone and number two is
um
uh you know there's a huge advantage
being a latecomer
especially in 2018 and now looking back
i think a major part of bible success
attribute to the
to the fact that we were not the ones
eating the crab the first person
or the first guy who invented the whale
so we were able to
take a model uh of uh say bit max or
okay x is a
concept of perpetual contract and sort
of build on it so from the
infrastructure level we can actually
bear in mind that uh solving the
overload or the server stability issues
is what we're
doing for so from the very bottom we can
actually build something
more solid so that gives us a huge edge
uh
well thanks to the you know uh the the
the uh
the first guys that designed this whole
thing but
we were able to take it and sort of uh
uh build on it
so that gives us the edges the lidcomber
and uh
and now we can do more uh with it you
know so um
i i think this is one of the things and
i was also at the time
i found a few very good partners that
can help me to
to achieve this uh this by bit uh
project um and that's how we decided to
go with it
yeah got it and so when you got started
like what was the idea in terms of what
did you guys set out to build
uh the very first version was we want to
build a
platform that offers uh derivatives
starting with perpetual contract and
then gradually moving into all different
products as we are doing now still
uh we're working on our exploration
contract and even options
and also just to refine it we want to
sort of
copy the model uh if you say someone who
invented the
the car but the japanese toolkit and
really sort of refined it
and that's our model is to really build
the product and more design for retail
uh we
our pure focus is on retail so the bible
product
whenever you see uh we have a new
product launching it's
already sort of everything out of the
box we
want to give our customer the feeling
that um it's like getting a new iphone
we opened it
everything is ready everything is
already packed inside uh
it's already been polished and uh very
retail friendly
so this was the idea it was a purely
retail focus the derivative exchange
built for the retail and even now we
have been
pushing on our mobile app for half a
year and putting a bunch of new features
into our mobile app
and we start to see that a lot of our
users you know are turning and
changing the training behavior into the
mobile app so the original assumption
that you cannot do professional trading
on mobile app we believe it's the whole
reason is because there wasn't a mobile
app available for people to do
so so all most of the exchange offered
the mobile app
as a supplement or an easy way to trade
but we want to focus on the mobile app
as we see the trend
and really make make it a weapon sort of
because crypto is 24 7. and
and it goes perfectly well with a mobile
trading uh equipment so um
we want to take advantage of that and
really devote our energy into this type
of retail focused uh
apps and products yeah so for the couple
of people who are listening who don't
know what a derivatives exchange is
maybe just explain
what that is um yeah it's a
uh you know a kind of a margin leverage
trading using uh margin to trade uh
bitcoin or ethereum or ripple
um we currently offer four different
peers uh
both linear contract and universe
contract
linear meaning you can use usdt usdt to
trade and it's settled in usdt
uh you can go up to 100 leverage uh so
that if you have i don't know
if you want to trade ten thousand
dollars you can use
literally one thousand uh dollars of
usdt to trade and
so you can you can limit sort of the
counterparty risk by not putting too
much coins on
an exchange by using leverage uh i heard
a lot of people using that yeah so yeah
got it and so you guys go and you launch
and you kind of took the world
by storm right in terms of you really
hit marketing
and the affiliate programs and all of
that um
in a kind of a big way maybe talk
through a little bit once you guys had
built the product what were those things
that you did to kind of get the word out
and really start driving adoption
uh very good question actually it's one
of the questions i haven't talked about
so much
it's uh i i think what we very original
stage that
early stage that we did sort of
something that changed the industry is
how
affiliation system works uh so when we
built the
launch the uh bitcoin perpetual contract
in
december 2018
after about three months there wasn't so
much volume
and interest coming in uh we realized we
need to focus on really
getting people to know our product um so
this is a game based on my previous uh
effects knowledge which is very
developed in the affiliation system
program we looked at the competition
across
board uh there was bimx okay x and even
binance
the affiliation is more of a referral
program
it's a very simple page with your link
and that's it
so and then we sort of talked to all of
the kols at the time
youtubers twitter guys and you know
across
all over the globe and their feedback
was that
their main source of income was mainly
from a shout out well i give you a shout
out i charge you you know 200 bucks and
this type of deal
i realized well they could be making so
much money and utilizing their their
their conversion and their
their traffic by simply working on the
affiliation deal but they couldn't do so
because the data was not there the data
was not transparent they could not
and analyze their action so what we did
is we basically
built a affiliate crm
for them to be able to at least see uh
they can create different campaigns so
they
for you palm you can create a youtube
campaign a twitter campaign
with different campaign you can use
different links uh with different links
we give you all the chartings all the
clicks how many clicks how many
conversions how much uh
how much traffic was coming in so in a
way you can you can you can start to see
the
the testing their behavior so they could
be saying
uh buy a bit check out buybits uh it's
no overload
and then they leave it for a week and
the next one they could say check out
buybit uh
there is uh uh no kyc for example
uh so whichever link has more traffic
they will be pushing that link more and
then sort of uh
really developed their whole energy into
into promoting
exchange so after we launched that and
along with that there was a
uh also a spike in price movement in
april
2019 uh that really uh
gave us a huge uh a lot of client
acquisition
and you can start to see that what we
changed is that
from being uh charging shout outs uh
affiliates are now
fully being a a baby promoter and
actually can earn income sort of
so this is the way uh we originally
started the the
how people get to know them but
obviously once you get
people to know them retention is the key
is to actually have a solid product
so that client try you and they like you
they stay so we actually have one of the
highest
retention in the industry uh uh we have
i think almost
60 percent so every 10 people who uh
register by bit would end up making
deposits at least 60
of them so um this is because our
product is is user friendly it's built
for retail and they can find us 24 7 for
the
for customer support all of that whole
package so in the end
it is the whole package but in the
beginning this is what we did to get the
initial
uh ball rolling yeah and i think one of
the other things that i've heard people
talk about with buy bit is not only was
uh it really built for an analytic
standpoint around the affiliate program
but also the way that you um compensated
people in that affiliate program was
kind of unique and so i've heard a lot
of people come to me and say hey look
like i make more money with bibit than
uh any other exchange that i work with
maybe talk a little bit just about that
that compensation structure and how you
guys thought about that
and built it um the compensation
is rather simple uh but uh people
i get i guess once you give them full
data transparency
we don't give them the client
information of course but they can
actually
see that uh if a uid is registered
because the uid is the internal buybit
number so there's nothing conflict about
that
they can see a uid registered uh how
much has been trade either is taker
volume or or maker volume
and how much commission they be made
from that client
and if they create different campaign
they can actually target let's say if
i'm in the
signal group i can see the roi on my
signal group
or versus the uh on my discord group
let's say
um so with the data transparency it
it gives a lot of affiliate ideas that
they can make more and all that but i i
believe true
they probably could make more because
the product the retention or
all of that in terms of payment we just
give them a cut on the
on the fees we collected so we charge
our clients a taker fee
uh of 7.5 bibs which is uh
same as is industry standard and we also
give a rebate on whoever providing us
liquidity uh by giving a 2.5 bibs rebate
on the maker volume
and the affiliates would share that
taker volume um
share that taker volume fees another
reason
is because the platform is overall it
built for retail
a lot of retail clients tends to use a
taker
strategy so that is why if they compare
with let's say
bmx or ftx maybe ftx has a lot of quants
or api traders
which can be a lot of maker volume so
i guess that whole thing we built for a
retail and they have retail audience
that's what makes buybit is very good
for conversion
so i don't think it's the actual payment
structure but it's
the product is built for their clients
so they have a better conversion
in the end they get better paid for for
the commission yeah
yeah that's awesome and then you guys um
have been spending a lot of time on your
mobile app
uh you said earlier that um you know you
saw kind of some trends where people
wanted to use the app maybe
talk a little bit about those trends and
kind of what drove you to put so much
time and effort into
building up the mobile app so originally
we built the mobile app uh purely for
our asian users
because there were so many requests from
japanese korean and
the chinese users of private uh asking
for
a mobile app before the mobile app we
had a
mobile website so when you visit from a
mobile phone
it will show a web.baby.com it's sort of
a new layout and structure for
for the mobile but they want a mobile
app
so what we did is okay let's build this
product uh
and we can use some of the a real cool
function of a mobile app
that is the notification features so
what's the best thing about
mobile app is that you can find the user
anytime
when they are you know uh i don't know
go to the toilet or people take their
phone with them so that's the only thing
you can find your client anytime pretty
much
uh and push notification you can utilize
that
so uh in the very original version one
of the mobile app we already had a
very simple price alert function where
if they can set if bitcoin price reached
certain level we push we give you a
notification
but recently we pushed out a strategy
alert that is
one much more step ahead on top of
the the simple price alert you can
actually set different indicators
uh meaning if you have moving average
you can set two moving average with
different period
and once when they cross each other we
will send you a notification
i let you know that movement is
happening or a lot of people let's say
they care about the
exchange funding fees or the funding
rate especially the predicted funding
rate
meaning that how many uh people are
overselling or oversold
in our older book so we can give them a
notification based on that factor
and also we plan to put in much more
indicators such as fibonacci macd and
all that useful ones
so that people can rely on these things
to
tell them when the market is moving and
and as far as further trend is going
uh yeah sorry i got distracted a little
bit uh
in the beginning it was built for the
asian users but uh
right now for example 80 of our japanese
users
are on our mobile app uh i would say 70
of our korean users on mobile app uh
but our uh mean english european markets
are now
slowly gaining market share on the
mobile app
from originally 30 now to about uh 50
so you can see a big trend of everyone
started using it
as we gave more capability onto the
mobile app
and they like it and that's one of the
most feedback we get uh
a lot of people choose buyba simply
because our mobile app
so um i really intend to invest much
more on to the development of that
yeah 50 to 80 of users in certain
countries using the mobile app is insane
like i would not have expected it to be
that high japan
is insanely high i would never expected
that but japan it was
before we offered the mobile app
everyone was using the web version but
once
we have the move everyone switched so it
was it was it was very surprisingly
surprising to me as well
why do you think that they're using the
mob is it literally just because they're
on the move
kryptos 24 7 and this is an easy way to
do it
and the app has enough functionality to
kind of do what they need to do or is it
something else
uh i think that's that's exactly
probably what it is uh
especially during the weekends uh i
guess people cannot be staring on the
in front of the pc all the time yeah and
that sort of gives you the habit
once you start to use in the mobile app
because maybe
you're using to pc version quite often
but at one weekend you have to go away
you start using the mobile you
realize oh it got all the tools i need
they got everything then he start to
rely on it it's like how you
start to use tick-tock you know it's uh
before you install it you never knew you
liked it
and then you start to give you the hook
you know yeah
are you on tick-tock you know what i
recently just delayed it because i
i found it it's such a addictive thing i
actually deleted it last week because uh
it's costing me too much time
i love that so one of the other things
that i know you guys have built into the
mobile app is almost this like uh
predictive type uh functionality right
where i can basically say
hey uh tell me when a certain uh
asset hits a certain price or tell me
when you know some event happens send me
a push notification
that's kind of like an alert system but
it sounds like you're kind of moving
towards maybe in the future you'll be
able to actually
um you know kind of know what the user
would want to know even if they didn't
set the alert
and can i send a push notification is
that accurate or is that a little bit
farther out
yeah in that system we want to advance
into more
even uh automated trading uh for our
mobile users
for example if you we if you start to
use
different indicators and you want us to
let you know that when this indicator is
happening
or certain price hits the trigger point
we can the next step is to connect the
conditional order or limit order
system into the notification so once
let's say
your fibonacci hits certain resistance
you want to do a conditional order in
uh we can set it up for you and of
course the the amount on all that you
can set yourself
so this is one more step towards the the
mobile app and that's sort of where
eventually we want to take this whole
thing is that people can
really don't need to monitor the phone
anymore
it becomes completely automated and you
can do all these
you can we can empower our user to
become sort of a quant trader in a way
that uh you don't have to know code to
be able to do this type of automated
simple automated trading yeah
yeah it makes a lot of sense and then um
when when your team reached out to me to
uh to
uh do this uh they were reaching out
because they wanted to talk about the
world series of trading right
and so uh we're um go ahead and
promoting that on the podcast in terms
of the sponsorship
but i said hey i wanna talk to ben right
if we're gonna we're gonna do this let's
talk to ben get him on here
so tell us a little bit about the the
world series of trading
i mean kind of what you guys are trying
to accomplish with uh with that
initiative
uh yeah so we started we were the first
one that started a global competition
in 2019 and that reached one a huge
scale
close to 8 000 people and it was a team
based where we had
i think 30 to 40 teams from china 20
teams from korea
uh 10 15 teams from japan and then the
rest
50 different teams from you know our
main markets which is english european
market
youtubers twitter guys leading different
teams
so it was a battle and it was sort of a
hype at the moment
where people was talking about it and uh
discussing strategies and all that
and this time we want to make it sort of
even bigger
and make it into a a regular occurring
event so we changed the name from
a simple btc competition to wsot
uh this is a reference to pokerstar wsop
you know
that kind of idea and we want to make
the big price so this
time the maximum price price pool is 200
btc
and this time it's still similar uh
concept with different teams different
countries will join
uh we want to make it a truly global
event and and also
uh let our clients see that we actually
have global
uh huge presence all over the place
different countries
uh but this time not only crypto we
actually got some uh uh poker people
joining us leading some teams we got
that park gonna be leading a team
uh mike mcdonald's going to be leading a
team
and of course your regular poker uh your
regular twitter guys
um uh youtubers um so
with that being said we want to sort of
use this event to make a social event so
everyone can
you know communicate and discuss and
have a little bit of fun
so we're going to be also launching a
chat room
function that our clients be asking a
lot so people can actually chat among
each other
and even trash talk if they want and
show off their profit and and otherwise
know that
yeah yeah that's awesome when um
when you're thinking about kind of where
we are in uh in the life cycle of crypto
you guys have been working on the
business now
for um for kind of three years give or
take uh you've grown into one of the
larger exchanges um
in the industry how do you think about
um kind of the last three years
of price movement of kind of the
building out of infrastructure
of uh seeing some of the larger
financial organizations come in like how
do you think we're doing and how do you
just think about like
where we are in crypto today
um i i think definitely there has been a
lot more
product focused team and product
oriented people coming into the space so
it's a good thing i think after the
whole 2017
uh ico it got a lot of hype and
a lot of people are interested um
now from 2018 they're joining into the
industry and you start to see different
teams build a different product
a lot of teams are very team product
focused
so i would say instead of only focusing
on the
white paper and concept stage we're
actually moving into a
very solid people are building product
and delivering product
at that type of a stage and like you
said
we also made some investment recently
into different projects
one is being a paradigm which is a
sort of uh uh rfq otc
type of uh software uh we were very
impressed with the team and the product
so
we think there's some synergy going on
there and that's why we we made some
investment and hopefully we will be
integrating to them very soon
um and just from a exchange perspective
um
there are a lot more institutions coming
in now um
even talking to buy bits uh trying to
connect to us
you know give us liquidity and then
trade uh with
with our api um so i i think it's
definitely uh
the the you know we see some good good
uh progress in crypto
and and to be honest uh for myself and
for my team
uh even through this whole epidemic
it's almost like a a belief top-up i i
tell my team that uh
through this epidemic uh the whole team
is
uh believe in blockchain that crypto
just rises
through the ceiling the reason being
that you start to see that
governments are shamelessly printing
money
like before you think they are kind of
still hiding but now they just
you know they're sprinting and you start
to see that because of that the
consequences are
uh the rich are getting billing out but
the poor the inequality is so bad um
and you see that stock and everything is
going up but
if you're living on if you have no
access to capital or and you're just
working at minimum wages
that 14 uh 14.15 per hour it's been
diluted like how
so you start to see there's a huge river
in between people who have access to
capital and people who are just basic
labor
and and there has to be revolution so a
lot of people say the
first age of revolut the first uh part
of the
internet age is the revolution of the
information
decentralize whatever of information i
believe the second part
second age is the revolution of capital
of money and
of the whole financial system so we
think we want to make sure that we stay
in the game and
we stay solid we built a product that's
ready for mass adoption
um so we're ready for when that comes
and contribute to this and
on the hand crypto is something
completely
uh the whole the whole um about about
the whole society about the whole uh
you know the everyone gets benefited so
this is why uh
we believe in so much yeah yeah and what
about
in china and kind of greater asia right
so a lot of people listening
um are in the united states and about 50
of people listening are gonna be outside
the united states right now
but you've got kind of this unique seat
where um you sit
in asia uh but you've got clients are
kind of across the world so how do you
look at
the development uh and adoption of
crypto
in asia versus maybe other parts of the
world
i'm actually surprised in asia it's uh i
would say
is more more adopted
we were entering into indonesian market
with one of the market you would
assume it's not so developed in terms of
crypto and all that
so we went in with this assumption of
assuming we need to do a lot of things
and then you go and you start to see wow
all this exchange extremely
well structured and uh they have their
own
indo setter they have their regulations
completely legalized and all these
companies
i think the largest one is called
indodex so people can actually go to
indo dex
at the counter and actually buy crypto
uh and it's completely legal
and the government accepted so
that that's took us by surprise and then
you go to philippines
where we have actually our office in
philippines also crypto
is legalized and you can get licensed
there and for china i guess everyone
knows the
uh the uh there's a a stable coin that's
been releasing the dc uh decp whatever
it's called so i think china wants to
take this advantage to
sort of uh uh you know uh change the
current structure of usd
usd uh and uh and put
sort of the the chinese r b into the
world stage by
uh combining with with crypto and
blockchain so
overall i think uh uh the hype in asia
is bigger even and people have stronger
beliefs and there was also
recently a a blockchain wake happening
in shenzhen in china
uh where there were a lot of people went
there and you can see the hype even
you know you never thought you see so
many people after this epidemic
but everyone is there uh and everyone's
talking about uh
you know d5s and everything uh so i
i i think definitely asia is is where
the action is happening actually
yeah yeah and what about like just
people who are not in the crypto
industry
uh in china or other parts of asia like
what do they think about the chinese
digital currency that that uh the
government there is planning to launch
is there people talking about it do they
know about it do they not care
uh to be honest i i think the whole uh
the chinese stable coin is very murky
right now
nobody knows even the people in the
industry talk to everyone's just
guessing uh
nobody knows what the central bank is
doing or the bank of china is trying to
test
um i i still think uh at this stage
people in the crypto industry are still
unclear
uh but we definitely start to see that
we're doing a lot of hiring right now
and we see a lot of good candidates and
they sort of they they come into the
infant
interview uh being that oh i see that
china is sort of bullish on the whole
blockchain and crypto
uh industry that's why i'm coming here
for this interview
and they always bring out this news that
oh the central bank is is coming out
with a stable coin
but if you ask them what do they know
they don't know anything
but they at least they take a signal
that is positive the government is going
to
move ahead with it so they want to be
the first uh
in the industry to find out what so they
want to join to find out uh
what's going to happen but they asked me
and we were like well we still don't
really know
at the moment but we also i i know as
much as you do so
so this is what's going on going on yeah
yeah and it's pretty interesting too
because i think as you get like the rise
of d5 right and kind of these
decentralized or automated products
um do you think that whether it's the uh
chinese digital currency
bitcoin or something else do you think
that the average user in asia
is open to using those products for
financial services over like the legacy
institutions
or do you feel like there's still some
loyalty to
the legacy financial institutions and
crypto is really only for trading and
kind of
investing if you will but not
necessarily the more traditional
financial services
um are you asking about china or uh
china specifically
china specifically to be honest my this
is only my personal take
i personally take it is uh uh
i don't think the chinese mainstream
will be using defy
to replace the current you know the
legacy uh
services one of the reason being that um
the existing service let's say alipay or
you know tencent all these different
financial tools
are so convenient um there are a lot of
people
i know a lot of my friends that are
either americans or you know from
from uk when they move back to the u.s
they feel very uncomfortable because a
lot of these things are not available
anymore it's so
convenient being china but obviously you
give up certain things you give up the
uh your your privacy so in a way it's a
trade-off you give you have no privacy
yeah
so uh but given that being said uh
all these tools what chinese are
currently using and used to are so
convenient there's
no need and that there's no concept of
why do i need to change
and and you can sort of also this whole
debate about privacy
uh if you never had something you you
sort of you don't really know
you know you know so if you never had
privacy and you
you never also you don't see people on
weibo talk about
different privacy issues but where you
see a lot of that in
twitter on that which is i i don't
necessarily personally agree with but um
but this is what the chinese uh uh
current stat
is so being that um if you're trying to
push out a defect and
sell people that hey if you use this
thing at least you get your privacy
people like well i'm perfectly happy
with what i'm saying right now so
this is the uh the dilemma we're facing
right now but
uh should it be changed uh definitely i
i believe so i believe uh wisdom fight
will change a lot of things and my
belief is that
maybe with that whole revolution of
crypto and and that will push
the things changing a bit in china as
well yeah
yeah and one of the last things i want
to talk about was just uh building a
team
right so you've done a fantastic job of
uh kind of
gathering very smart people very quickly
and that built
a very profitable business have how have
you
found hiring uh whether it's there in
china or
globally uh before we get started you
were telling me how
you guys kind of were very used to
working remotely and kind of using all
the different remote tools
but obviously you're looking for the
best people so talk a little bit about
kind of building your team and how you
found that hiring process
we take hiring very seriously actually
all the hirings uh are the final
interviews
is definitely one of the founders even a
reception
person coming in that uh one of the
founders would
sit that last final round simply because
we want to make sure our people
understand the company culture they're
coming into
uh by presenting a founder and and
normally that gives them a little bit uh
a very positive feeling about the
company that or you really take care of
uh
you really care about the hiring process
but i mean right now uh as far
as far as hiring concern we actually
found through this epidemic
a lot of good candidate is is becoming
available
so we actually has been spending
massively
right now we have globally about more
than 250 people
so uh half of them uh more than half of
them
are you know hired probably during this
whole
six months um so uh and uh
we have uh we have one interesting round
i can share you that
normally the first run interview is the
hiring manager and the second round is
what we call
a cultural interview so all we're asking
uh is is this person coming from
completely different
units so if you're hiring a marketing
person this person is coming
from either i.t background or our
accounting department
we select them as our uh cultural
representative and and
they will be asking questions about uh
what do you like to play and
you know uh what uh what was your
preference what kind of people you hang
out with
like this and also they actually tell
the candidate about
uh what is working in in bible like
because
a lot of times the candidate is feeling
a little bit shy
asking kind of direct questions about
the line manager
so they asked the cultural interviewer
and the coaching reviewer their core
responsibility is to find out whether
this person have
client first mentality whether it's
being this person is sincere
um whether it's uh it's a goal-oriented
person and
a few criteria we want to find out and
they give a score
and if our cultural interview doesn't
pass
this person cannot be hired into the
company we rotate our
staff to do that so they take great
ownership on
an honor in doing this uh because they
feel you know i'm actually the person in
charge of
character i need to be extremely um uh
you know careful so it's uh i find that
it's very interesting and um
a lot of good positive feedbacks about
that process yeah
i love that i absolutely love that um
before i get into
the rapid fire questions to end it uh
what's your number one priority for the
second half of 2020 like what are you
most focused on
uh seeing buybit or your team do
we want to expand our current product
lines uh
like i said uh we are launching our
exploration contract
and also hopefully by q4 we want to
launch our option product
so we want to truly by this year expand
our product line
make sure whenever we release the
product it has some innovation in it
and that's why the past two products the
mutual insurance and the strategy alert
they're both
unique and uh you know so uh this is our
pure focus that we want to
lead the industry uh by innovating
product
and give the clients what they they want
yeah
i love that i finished each interview
with uh the same two questions the first
being what is the most important
book that you've ever read the most
important book uh you know what
i recently i recently uh
took a vacation and my
second son was just born uh two weeks
ago
so i was in the hospital and uh you know
holding him
and just on the shelf there was a book
called tuesday with maurice and
uh so i read that tuesday with maurice
this is a very good book about this
professor you know
uh uh dying words and giving a last life
lesson about
his vision how to treat life how to give
back to society and a lot of that
so it was it was very it was very uh
refreshing and uh for me it was good to
slow down
especially with uh in the hospital with
my kid just there
it's sort of awakening i was like okay i
need to slow down and focus more on live
and all that
so this is one of the recent book i read
uh
i found it very interesting yeah so uh
yeah
that sounds like a very strategically
placed book right is to put that in the
in the room probably my my wife put it
there
i love that uh the second question is a
little bit more fun
aliens believer or non-believer oh 100
believer
why uh especially after knowing that how
small we are
maybe before i didn't know uh but after
we found out the whole galaxy
and how small we are i'm sure there's
you know
maybe not in this galaxy but in
different galaxies there's something
uh being like uh either leicas or
uh civilization so uh
for sure i definitely believe in that
and uh yeah
you never know i think that is a
great way to look at it it's just the
world is so big right how do we know
what uh what could possibly be out there
uh to end it you get to ask me one
question so what is the one question
that you have for me
one question i have for you this is very
good
what was the one most interesting
question you asked and even to this day
you find it
interesting uh you kind of think back to
uh to one of
any of the people you interviewed yeah
um
most interesting question
or sort of awakening that kind of change
yeah yeah
yeah i'm gonna give you two uh two
answers so first of all the reason why i
asked the alien question is
i think it just gives you a pretty good
uh very quick
view into like how people think right so
some people
uh will come on and they'll say hey uh i
don't believe in aliens because
i've never seen one right somebody else
will come in and say i believe because
you know mathematic probability says
that you know it's more probable than
not
other people will come in and say i
believe because here's you know three
scientific equations and
and they're very analytical about it so
i think that uh it's just like my
favorite question because it can tell
you so much about the way somebody
thinks
uh what they believe um you know people
who want to believe aliens are real
versus people who
you know don't want to do and stuff like
that so i would say that's definitely
one
uh in terms of um
like my favorite question i
don't think i have one i think what it
ends up being
is uh there are times when i do an
interview and i'll ask a question
and somebody is so brutally honest with
their answer
that it almost makes them uncomfortable
and
i think that like when when you see that
happen
it's just a really special moment like
this person's so intellectually honest
and
so just transparent that they didn't
want to tell me what they just told me
but they didn't right
and so to me like it's just this uh this
vulnerability
that uh i think a lot of people they
will um
you know if you go on television for
example everyone is
trying to like project some image right
hey i'm the smart trader guy i'm the
smart this i'm the smart this you know
woman whatever
podcasts are a little bit different that
people are are more authentic and kind
of just you know have a conversation
uh so i think when you see people be
like overly vulnerable especially when
they say things that are true
but don't make them look good you're
just like man this is pretty cool
experience to kind of have those types
of conversations with people
yeah well awesome awesome absolutely
thank you
where can we send people to uh to find
you on the internet and then find out
more about buy bid or the world series
of trading
uh well i'm on twitter i'm always on
twitter so people can find me at uh
ben bybet you know at bimbit or
for wsot just go to buybit.com and
you'll be able to see some information
yeah it's all over the home page
absolutely awesome ben listen thank you
so much for taking the time to do this i
really enjoyed it
and congratulations with all your guys
success and let's do it again in the
future
thank you thank you looking forward to
the next talk
thank you